Marknadsföringen är också att man aldrig har något tak på marknadsföringen, utan då ska du aldrig sätta någon budget för att du inte ska annonsera mer än x kronor.
Så länge du kan kolla att den är lönsen så ska du ju vara frit blåstare att du kan annonsera hur mycket som helst.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, kan det inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dess bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Emil Jansson på Skolyx till podden.
Tjena Emil.
Vi bor ju i samma lilla bygd.
Jag vet inte om man säger bygd men det är ingen stor stad direkt.
Vi bor i någon sorts förort till Göteborg kan man säga.
Du är ju en trevlig människa men jag försöker undvika dig lite grann.
För att du är ju...
Dels har jag mött dig i löpspåret och du är snabbare än vad jag är.
Och så är du lite längre.
Och nu har du också en e-handel som...
Du kommer nog att takta förbi mig här om några år om du håller samma fart i tillväxten.
Hur känns det att vara Mönnlyckes finest?
Ja, jag titulerar mig något själv så men...
Nej inte än, men om två år.
Om två år.
Ja men då får vi ta ett par dagar, så inte om två år så får vi ta det.
Det är svårt att måla upp den vildare just nu.
Nu är du finest.
Jag ska sola i glansen här ett tag till.
Fan vad gott det känns.
Nu säger jag ju att du har en e-handel, men du är mitt i en butiksöppning.
Kan inte du bara, vi tar lite kort, du driver ett företag som heter Skolix.
Det är en e-handel, ni säljer skor på nätet, men det är lite bättre skor.
Ja, kvalitetsskor tillverkade i Spanien, och de har fått hjälp främst.
The real deal.
Exakt.
Men det är sagt, vi skiter i det en liten stund och så går vi in på, du håller på att öppna en butik.
Varför gör ni det och hur går det?
I fredags öppnar vi det, men det har gått över förväntan måste jag säga.
Den är öppen och det går att ta betalt och allting sånt där, så det får man ju vara nöjd med.
En lågt sagt ribba när ta betalt, det som krävs.
Vi drog igång den i fredags, vi har bara varit uppe två dagar, så det har ju tagit väldigt mycket tid och insatser från alla i hela gänget.
Men det har varit väldigt kul och skönt att äntligen komma igång.
Vi har funderat för det länge.
Senast var, precis innan corona var det nära att vi skulle öppna också.
Men det känns rätt bra att vi inte gjorde det då.
Jävla bra timing.
Men varför väljer man att öppna en butik?
Och var har ni öppnat den någonstans?
Det är på Södra Lärmgatan, inne i Göteborg.
För de som inte är kända i Göteborg så är det inte största Koppinggatan men samtidigt centralt och på ett bra ställe med mycket folk i rörelse och sådär.
Men det blir mer att man går till oss eller att man råkar gå förbi sådär än att det kommer alla turister in.
Är det för att folk ska kunna prova skor eller är det bara för att det känns lite coolt att ha en butik eller vad är anledningen?
Det måste ju vara krångligt.
Coolheten är ju inte främsta anledningen men det är av många olika anledningar.
Mycket är just för att vi ska se också hur underlaget är för kunder som inte handlar av oss online.
Man vet inte, många säger att jag köper aldrig skor på nätet och så där.
Man vet inte om folk vad säger det eller om det verkligen är att folk drar sig för att köpa skor på nätet.
Sen tror jag också att det är väldigt bra skyltfönster att visa att företaget finns på riktigt.
Redan när vi stod och renoverade kom det en kille in där och sa att det finns på riktigt.
Jag bara sätter annonser på nätet.
Så frågade jag om jag hade klickat eller kollat in i hemsidan.
Nej, jag klickar aldrig på någonting på nätet.
Jag var där det fredags och stod i butiken första dagen för att se hur det var så där.
Det var ju folk som kom in och handlade som inte hade köpt på nätet.
Men risk för att du ska säga något som är weird nu, men vad är en person som inte hade handlat på nätet som kom in och handlade?
Det var en som skulle köpa lite klädvårdsprodukter.
Under tiden när han gjorde det så tog hans fru på sig ett par skor bara från bordet.
Hon bara såg vad snygga det var.
Så tog hon på sig dem och sa att de skulle ha.
Okej jag fattar.
Man når ut till ett annat tjentel också.
Det är lite statistiskt signifikant efter tio kunder, men det ska bli intressant och roligt att se.
Jag tror också det ger en viss legitimitet att man har en fysisk butik där alla i Göteborg kan gå förbi, eller turister kan komma förbi och testa och se och prata med.
Sen digger vi mycket på expertkunskapen vi har också.
Vi kommer också kunna ge väldigt bra service där och ha en annan dialog med kunderna än vad man kan ha digitalt.
Har ni flyttat kontor och sånt dit också?
Nej vi har inte flyttat kontoret, utan vi har kvar vårt ordinarie kontor, men vi kommer ha arbetsplats där också.
Så tanken är att man ska kunna sitta där och jobba också.
Även om inte alla kan vara där samtidigt.
På något sätt är det ju att driva e-handel, jag vet att många e-handlare startar butik, men jag har räknat på det några gånger och jag får aldrig ihop det.
Och inte för att hyran egentligen är så brutal, för att på något sätt lägger man ju svin mycket på marknadsföring, men jag har aldrig fått ihop det när det gäller bemanning av butik, och du ska ha människor där, och helt plötsligt måste du börja jobba med scheman på ett helt annat sätt.
Stör inte det dig?
Jo alltså, schema och sånt kommer ju vara ett massa pussel med, men delvis kommer vi att bemanna det med ordinarie personal, under många stunder, och det är väl just därför också att vi kommer ha kontor där också, så att vi kan vara lite flexigare.
Sen har vi fått anställa två pers då, som ska jobba deltid i butik i det ju då.
Men som du säger, man lägger så pass mycket på marknadsföring, så att i jämförelse med det så är det ju nästan ingenting liksom.
Det är försvunbart i jämförelse med det kostnaden.
Det känns ju klart personal och sånt, det går ju på en del såklart.
Men vi hoppas ju att, är det jättemycket folk i butiken så då är det ju löst.
Är det inte så mycket folk i butiken så får de, då jobbar vi med andra saker.
Jag älskar den kalkylen, det är en underbar kalkyl att köra med.
Om någon hade, där kommit in ett sådant riskkapitabolag och så säger de, ja men ni har öppnat tio butiker här, det är en dyrkostnad, ja men inte om det är mycket sälj.
Men vi har ju tänkt lite så att det kommer att vara det som sagt mycket, och många tycker i personalen inte syr mig själv att det ska vara kul att vara där också.
Sen kommer inte vi stå i butiken varje dag, men vi kommer ha en kontorsplats där så man kommer kunna gå ut i butiken och hjälpa till om det blir mycket att göra.
Och vi kommer bli mannen hel del själva också, med egen personal, folk kommer göra olika saker.
Och delvis att stå i butik.
Och då har vi sagt att skulle det vara så mycket att man blir för mycket stående i butik, det är ju för att det har gått väldigt bra i så fall.
Och då är det ju redan en annan problem, då får vi anställa fler som jobbar i butik.
Ja, det ska bli spännande att se.
Det ska verkligen bli väldigt roligt.
Och sen på något sätt intalar jag mig ändå att om det går bra i Göteborg med butik så borde det ju gå bra i Stockholm med butik.
Göteborg är väl egentligen inte den första stan du hade velat starta i.
No offense till oss själva eller?
Absolut.
Det är ju både, det finns ju mycket större businessgäng i Stockholm och publiken vad det finns i Göteborg.
Sen är det ju lite större konkurrens.
Det finns lite fler skogbutiker och så där i Stockholm också.
Men vi tror ju att funkar det här så finns det ju fler andra städer som rent teoretiskt det fungerar minst lika bra i också då.
Nu har det varit liksom lågkonjunktur några år och ni säljer ju ändå en, nu kallar det säkert affordable premium eller något sånt där fancy, men ni säljer ju dyrare skor än vad jag köper som vi etablerade sist.
Men ni har gjort en jävla resa under de här senaste två åren, det har ju gått bra liksom.
Kan du berätta lite vad som har hänt de här åren och vad ni har gjort bra och vad har hänt liksom?
Ni ger oss lite hårda fakta, vad ligger ni och snurrar på nu?
Vi omsatte ju strax under 50 miljoner förra året, 49,7 miljoner och sånt där.
Hur bitter var du på den 300 000?
Nej inte alls faktiskt.
Jag tror att 99,9 hade varit tråkigare.
Det är inget jag har tänkt på.
Det gick ändå väldigt bra fart, framförallt sista halvåret förra året.
Så det är sedan ändå väldigt bra att komma upp det.
Men vad var det som fick bra fart?
Vad ni gjorde bra?
För ni har gjort en fördubbling på bara ett par år och det är ganska många extra skor.
Ja, jag kollade när vi poddade för två år sedan.
Då var det det vi pratade om att vi sålde väldigt mycket i Sverige av våra omsättningar och nu har vi framförallt i Norden, Norge, Danmark, viss del Finland och sedan även börjat för traction utanför Norden också.
Och då finns det också helt annorlunda.
Man jobbar ju med mycket större målgrupp, det finns ju boende till så många i Sverige så att man börjar få fester i Tyskland och i UK och sådana länder då finns det mycket större potential också.
Vilken marknad är det som har tagit fart mest?
Vilka är det som är mest sugna på bättre skor?
Norge och Danmark är det ju.
Jag lyssnade igenom podden snabbt där, den vi körde för två år sedan och då pratade vi mycket om att om vi omsatt till 20 miljoner i Sverige borde vi kunna omsätta i alla fall hälften av det i Norge och Danmark.
Och det är mycket det när vi gör det, då tar det ju fartar vi såklart.
Norge är ju en skitmarknad tullmässigt och Danmark säger att de är en skitmarknad för att de retinerar allting.
Kan du berätta hur ni har bemött kunderna och svårigheterna med de två marknaderna?
Det kanske är värre för dig som har så stora grejer, men för oss är det ganska smidigt.
Vi hade ju 3PL i Norge innan, där vi sålde Storcellerna i Norge, men nu skickade vi allting från Sverige istället.
Så det hjälpte väl att bygga upp lite volym innan man började skicka.
Det är svårt att skicka om att du har något flöde.
Alltså om du bara skickar instakar, parkerat eller något svårt att få ihop.
Men nu kan du skicka palvar idag, så då om det lättar ju det.
Och Danmark, nej vi märker inte av det faktiskt.
Men vi är ju också lite så, vi jobbar ju mycket utbildande och förklarar mycket på hemsidan kring storlekar och modeller och sådär.
Så det är inget vi har märkt av att det skulle vara något större problem med retur där än på andra ställen.
Tyskland är ju mer retur.
Men Danmark är inget som vi har reagerat närmare på.
Okej, jag fattar.
Du är ju alltid lite blygsam och självutplånande i din sån här...
Kan du inte...
Mitt mål här idag är ju att få dig att skryta lite grann och vara lite kaxig.
Kan du skryta lite eller kan du förklara vad ni har gjort jävligt bra i Norge och Danmark?
Hur kunde ni få sån volym så fort?
Det vi har gjort i Sverige, vi försökte verkligen samla ihop allt det vi har gjort i Sverige för att applicera på Norge och Danmark.
Och vad är det då?
I Sverige finns det flera egentligen som säljer skor och skovård och sådär.
Men vi är ju absolut störst.
De flesta säljer bara skor, vi säljer skor och skovård och klädvård och sådär.
Och vi märker när vi väl når det ut och folk testar då sprider vi sig ganska mycket mellan folk.
Det är inte så att vi måste pumpa in marknadsföring och köpa till förlust tillväxten.
Utan vi märker att när det väl börjar öka försäljningen för massor så sprider vi sig.
Vi har översatt hela sajten till både norska och danska.
Vi gör det ganska ordentligt.
Vi har i Danmark en journalist som hjälper oss att gå igenom översättningarna.
Så det är inte bara att vi kör chatgrupp ter hela sajten och så blir det så där.
Utan vi har liksom en som är journalist och kan skor och samgör det där.
Så vi försöker alltid få den ett stort vinkel som vi har i Sverige, försöker vi få på andra länder också.
Det är nog ganska unikt för oss i vår bransch.
De flesta kör engelska rakt av och så får det funka för hela världen liksom.
Hur har ni gjort med prissättning?
Vi säljer också till Danmark till exempel och vi har ju bara översatt priserna och det är ett jävla flum med...
Euron har ju inte gått lika mycket som dollarn upp och ner och så där.
Men våra priser i Danmark ser lite halv skeva ut.
Hur har ni gjort med prissättningarna?
Tänker du Danmark med danska kronor specifikt eller?
Ja men då har vi ju...
det är ju dyrare att sälja.
Man får ju så här...
Det är högre avgift på såna här kortbetalningar och sånt där också så att det blir lite högre än att sälja till någon med sysch i Sverige liksom.
Så då lägger man ju på några procent för det, alltså några procent för valutaväxling.
Och så rundar man av alla priser med tjatt-GPT så det ser snyggt ut på sista sittra.
Det är väl så vi gör.
Så danskarna betalar typ 10 procent mer?
Ja, någonstans.
Har du inte bara testat att höja de svenska priserna 10 procent?
Jo, märkligt en bodak.
Så det är såklart alltid något man jobbar med med priset.
Sen så ligger vi alltid, vi har ju väldigt pressade marginaler jämfört med våra konkurrenter.
Det är många konkurrenter som säljer via återförsäljare också.
Då har de ju helt andra marginaler såklart.
Sen kanske vi har varit lite dåliga historiskt på att höja priserna.
Vi har varit lite rädda för det men har gjort det senaste två åren har vi höjt priserna.
På grund av att det blivit ökade kostnader för oss också med allting.
Vi har ju gått upp råvarupriser och länare hos fabriker och allting.
Vi har gått upp såklart som vi har höjt också.
Så det tycker jag ändå att vi har parerat bra nu.
Vi var mycket räddare förra åren med våra helt priser.
Alltså på något sätt, om ni skulle fortsätta den här kurvan uppåt, om ni liksom fortsätter på inslagen väg, är du lite nervös för nästa dubbling?
För det hände ju ganska mycket med logistik, inköp, flöd, hela likviditetscirkeln.
Allting blir ganska krångligt ju större volymer det blir, för man kan inte bara lägga in 10 000 kronor privat och se att det löser problemet.
Det hände ju mycket.
Hur har du planerat upp för nästa drift här?
Nu någonstans är ni ju inte en liten start-up eller en liten hobbyverksamhet, jag menar att det var det för två år sedan.
Jag bara menar att det är en jävla skillnad på att omsätta 20 och omsätta 50.
Och den jävla omskillnaden att omsätta 50 och omsätta 100 helt plötsligt är det mycket volym och mycket pengar som snurrar.
Hur tänker du kring nästa steg?
Det har jag märkt nu när vi är dubbelt så stora.
Man kan inte bara chansa i vägen order och ta i lite extra och så har vi lite säkerhetsmarginal.
Det blir mycket större kostnader när man går snett när man ska sälja för 50 eller särskilt sen när man ska sälja för 100.
Sen vi omsatte 20 så har vi anställt en tjej som är ansvarig för logistik.
Det har jag gjort mycket att någon kan sitta med det på heltid.
Nu sitter inte jag med det länge, vilket är väldigt bra.
Sen har vi också skaffat system på ett helt annat sätt.
Inköpssystem och sådana saker som hjälper oss att prognostisera är det.
Men sen när man omsätter 100, skillnaden där kommer att vara att vi kommer att behöva vara mycket petigare med laggrundsättning och sådär.
Nu har vi inte direkt behövt tänka så mycket på det men när det blir mycket större volym och sen kommer vi behöva vara mer restriktiva med vad vi tar in och vad vi lagar för.
Du sa ni prognostisera, det måste vara ganska knepigt att prognostisera skor.
För jag tänker dels att det är sjukt säsongsberoende och sen har ni massa storlekar som gör att det blir lite halvflummigt.
Och sen tar ni väl fram nya modeller på ett annat sätt än...
Alltså vi har ju liksom produkter som har funnits i 15 år och så snurrar de bara.
Det är så enkelt för oss att se om en produkt ska ersätta en annan produkt.
Jag gissar att ni inte riktigt jobbar på det sättet.
Det måste fortfarande vara rätt mycket magkänsla eller?
Ja, väldigt mycket magkänsla är det.
Sen så kan vi ju...
Vi jobbar ju mycket med klassiska skor och modeller.
Sen har vi även såklart mycket sånt här lite mer casual med sneakers och sådär också.
Det är lite mer...
Där kanske man inte har samma färg eller samma modell lika länge men det har ju skor som har funnits i 100 år.
I vårt grundutbud liksom en klassisk svart och x-ford det har ju funnits och kommer ju finnas för evigt antagens.
Men med sneakers kan det ju vara lite variant som kommer och går och där intresset är lite olika och sådär som vi ser mig först nu egentligen när våren kommer och folk börjar handla där vad som går i år ordentligt.
Men vi tillverkar ju allt i Spanien och Portugal också så vi har ganska korta ledtider skulle jag säga ändå.
Det är ju inte så att man måste vänta på en båt från Asien och flera månader utan vi kan ju fortfarande beställa saker som kommer innan sommaren.
Så att det är underlätt och att man kan justera lite längs vägen där.
Och ni behöver inte köpa in material, jag tänker så här läder och sådana grejer.
Det är inte ni som löser det utan fabrikerna får läsa det.
Ja vi kan göra det om vi vill, men vi jobbar så pass nära med fabrikerna så det är mer bara att de kan lite gärna beställa det som vi.
Vi bestämmer vilket garv i och vad det från läder ska komma men så köper de in allting.
Jag bara tänker att det är också en sådan där, det ska absolut korta i ledtiden men de ska ju ha material på lager.
Det är ju en utmaning ibland att de tar inte riktigt höjd för det vi vill att de ska ta höjd.
Är det Sydeuropa, är det de som är kick ass på det här?
Jag tycker ofta jag hör liksom Portugal, eller framförallt Portugal tycker jag jag hör ofta.
Är de så duktiga på detta?
Jag bodde ju i Portugal några år och jag besökte aldrig någon skoaffär liksom.
Nej men det är ju, de har ju olika regioner där alla jobbar med skor utensivt.
Då är det inte bara skofabriker utan även de som gör skolsnören och sulor och allting görs nästan på samma ställe.
Så är man nere där kan man åka mellan alla fabriker samtidigt nästan.
Så de har ju stor erfarenhet där det är och sen även i Spanien.
På Mallorca gör vi våra egna skor då.
Du pratar lite grann om att ni driver mycket content som är utbildande och ni försöker liksom vara med kunden och guida och så där.
Kan du inte prata lite grann om det och vad det faktiskt innebär mer än att det finns en tabell på hemsidan som säger vilken storlek man ska ha?
Om jag liksom kommer in i ett flöde, vad hamnar jag i för flöde då?
Hur kommer jag att fatta vad jag ska använda?
Det är ju något bak sig butiken har vi märkt.
Där får man ju många sådana frågor när folk kommer in.
Så det tror jag att vi kommer att vara mycket nyttade av det här.
För det är inte alls självklart vad man ska göra.
Vi har ju väldigt brett supplement.
Så jag fattar att det är svårt att veta vad du ska välja.
Vilka reningöresprodukter du ska ha till vilka skor och vilket material och sådär.
Så dels har vi en guide-sektion på hemsidan där du kan gå in och läsa.
Men jag fattar också att man inte går in och läser en lång insökingsbok.
Utan ofta vill du bara ha...
Jag har ett par vita sneaker som är smutsiga, vad ska jag göra?
Sådana där frågor får vi mycket.
Så sen sist har vi...
Jag får bara, det har ju inte vi köper.
Menar du att folk ringer till er och frågar, hej jag har smutsiga skor, hjälp mig.
Ja, ja.
Det är ju jättevanligt så här, polare som är av sig, min dotter är någon och att de lerar igen, och ett par nya vita nej, kärrhus kommer jag att renta.
Och då vill de bara veta kort och enkelt ut vad man ska ha.
Och sen vi har ju pratat sist, nu har vi chatt på hemsidan också, där går det också att styra av väldigt mycket, och bara direkt säga vad det är man ska ha.
Och det är ju inga 10 000 kronor spesifikt, det är några hundra lappar för rätt skovård, och så får du snabbt tipsa nu.
Och sen kommer de kanske att köpa skolor nästa gång, när de väl har sett att vi har bra service, snabba leveranser och så där.
Okej, men guidningen handlar mest om skovård, eller hur man ska hantera själva skoen då, eller förvaringen kanske, men handlar inte så mycket om här är vad du borde ha på dig, eller här är det.
Det som jag tänker är att, hur gör man en sån här produkt tillgänglig för gemenimannen?
Ja, nu blir det som att jag pratar om detta hela tiden, men liksom, jag är ju en rätt basic människa, du har ju träffat mig några gånger.
Alltså det är ju liksom, nu senast så skrev jag i kontorschatten här, då skrev jag, hej, vad heter sådana här snören som liksom drar åt sig själva på skorna?
Jag ska försöka hitta de skorna jag köpte för två år sedan, och jag vill ha samma skor, och då blev jag ju fullkomligt hånad i den där, de tycker jag ska ha sådana kardborreband i stället, men då köpte jag de där.
Men det har ju också, om jag skulle liksom klicka in på er sida eller jag skulle gå utanför er butik, så hade jag ju tyckt att den var lite läskig.
Du vet, jag hade ju känt mig jävligt dum om jag gick in där, det hade känts som att så här, hej, hej, hej, är det här en sko man har på sig innan man träffar folk?
Alla människor kan ju inte skor, hur gör man så att man blir tillgänglig för nästa omgång människor som borde köpa skor för de sitter på ett kontor?
Innan corona hade vi nästan bara dressat, riktiga sådana här dressade skor.
Och då fattar jag mycket med det där att gå in, då hade man ju väldigt många blivit avskräckta att gå in och bara sett, liksom, välputsade, alltså, svarta, välputsade löneskor, liksom, det fattar jag ju då.
Men nu har vi ju väldigt mycket mer, vi har ju mycket sneakers och min dotters kompisar var i våra skor och det finns liksom, min dotter har den inte själv men, för att det är pappas skor.
Men det är liksom, det finns många ungdomar och min fru har det och alltså, det är inte det här bara dressade längre, utan du kan se ett par skissa sneakers i vårt skickens nu.
Så det tror jag minskar den barriären betydligt.
Då kanske du köper ett par sneakers och sen när du ska gifta dig då kanske du kommer ihåg att jag fick skissa service när jag köpt några sneakers så de hade faktiskt skor som var kraft på bröllop också.
Så vi har ju väldigt, väldigt bred publik så att säga.
Hur balanserar man upp det då så att du inte blir för mainstream, alltså de som vill ha bra skor, kanske inte vill att, jag vet inte vad heter ungar, som är 15 år, men liksom Bosse 15 köper sina sneakers i samma butik utan de vill ju komma in där och liksom, fan här köper vuxna människor.
Hur balanserar man det?
Ja men vi, ja hittills har vi bara gjort det på hemsidan så då är det mer liksom att visuellt presentera det så att det inte blir bara liksom ser ut som en TikTok-site för femtonåringar liksom.
Så där kan man ju bara göra det men sen i butiker så får man ju också en balans kring det.
Men det handlar väl mycket också i bemötandet med den kunden som kommer in att då ger man ju det bemötandet till den kunden som vill ha den experthjälpen kring dressade skor liksom och de vet ju, de som är ut efter det de vet ju att vi är experter på dressat också.
Okej, det är etablerat.
Ja det är det, folk vet ju att vi är skoexperter liksom och duktiga på det, så det andra är ju mer som ett, däremot Cassity Rasa köper då, vad sa du, bussen 15, han Cassity vet att vi är skoexperter.
Så att det är nog mer och jag tror det har löst sig själv genom det ryktet vi har och det här svar vi har när man kommer in.
Men hur bibehåller ni det ryktet?
Sist nämnde du att ni hade någon podd som pratade om typ skor?
Nej, något sådant.
Min kollega Jesper, han är riktigt skonörd och har fritidsintresse också.
Så han skriver mycket content på sajten och han svarar också i alla kundtjänst och sådana saker också.
När det är expertfrågor då går det ju att ta honom och sådär.
Så vi har väldigt hög produkttexter och sådant.
Allting är liksom, det är liksom inte AI, vi matar lite sånt med AI, utan vi skriver det här med detaljerat på ett expertvis.
Det är det samma som ni har med gymgrejer, att man går in och kollar och ser och så har ni lite YouTube-videos och pratar mycket om era grejer.
Det gäller ju att leverera det och verkligen lägga ner riktigt med tid på det, som att du bara gör någon sån här följtext på varje produkt.
Finns det vissa, finns det liksom sko-influensörer här i Sverige?
Finns det människor ni samarbetar med som visar det?
Ja men några finns det.
Det här var ju vanligt, det följde med en sån här riktig boom kanske för tio år sedan, runt 2016.
Då var det ju en riktig boom med menswear kallades det ju då, med kostymer och skor och sådär.
Och då var det mycket större här.
Men nu finns det ju fortfarande några fåtal, ingen så just skorinfluencer tesservannels av, utan det är både kläder och skor egentligen.
Men internationellt finns det ju fler också som vi jobbar med.
Men ni driver inte egna influencerkonton där ni liksom verkligen pratar skor?
Nej, eller vi har ju Instagram har vi med vårt eget konto, där pratar vi skor och...
Men finns det inget Emil-konto där du liksom snackar produktion och tillverkning och allt sånt där?
Nej, utan det har vi på hemsidan, alltså där kan du kolla filmer från fabriken och sånt där.
Så det är där vi försöker kommunicera det.
Men va fan inte det, det måste väl ändå ganska...
Så här, det är väl rätt häftigt.
Ja, du menar att jag skulle ha det privat istället för att ha det på filmen.
Ja, varför har inte du ett konto där du snackar, snackar skor, du åker ner, kollar, här finns det här, så här, det här är mina favoriter.
Varför har inte du gått in i den världen lite grann?
Du kan väl föra dig?
Ja, men...
Är du blik?
Min kollega har ju det...
Ja, det är jag ju, eller...
Jag skiljer inte med...
Det är inte så att jag tänker att vi ska göra en kampanj, att vi ska ösa fram mig längst fram.
Nej men min kollega, Jester har ju det själv, så att säga.
Så han täcker upp mycket av det.
Det skulle liksom bli lite oviktigt om jag skulle försöka pärma honom och göra något likadant liksom.
Men där försöker vi hitta en balans och ha det på vår Instagram också.
Där har vi rätt mycket följare och så där.
Sen är det ju inte samma action på Instagram idag längre.
Folk orkar ju inte likea eller kommentera på samma sätt som man gjorde förr.
Nej, det har verkligen förändrats den världen.
De senaste tillväxtdrivarna som du pratade om, de var ju liksom att ni öppnade upp i ett par länder till, om man ska vara lite krass, och så fick ni igång försäljningen där.
Vad är nästa tillväxtdrivare som kommer här framöver tror du?
Vi bytte i site också, vi bytte i plattform förra året.
Så det la vi ett halvår också på att bara sitta och mata och byta plattform.
Hur gick bytet?
Vad bytte ni ifrån till?
Vad skete sig?
Vad skete sig inte?
Är du nöjd nu?
Ja, nu är jag jävligt nöjd.
Men vi bytte från Prestakop, så det var ju...
Du kallar mig agenter fortfarande, så det är ju open source, där man kunde hacka sönder allting.
Man kunde ju sitta direkt i koden och så försökte man hobbyfixa någonting och så gick det fel och så hittade man någon nyfunktion och så köpte man någon modul för 50 dollar som skulle revolutionera allt och så blev siteen lite slöare år för år.
Och så kraschade något annat samtidigt?
Ja, det hade vi vissa sidor som hade när det var så här paket som tog upp 45 sekunder och laddade, jag kommer ihåg, programmen.
Men, så då bytte vi plattform i maj förra året.
Så det är så att vi tog nästan ett halvår och sitta och flytta överallt.
Det var ju nästan tusen produkter eller över tusen produkter med bilder och allting så att det var...
Har du också blivit en av Shopify för äldsta människorna nu?
Vi kör Centra faktiskt.
Oj, ja det ser man.
Aha, jag förstår ni tillhör det goda gardet.
Är inte Centra alla kända varumärken?
Alla fancy varumärken?
Ja, några fancy har det då.
Även alla undrar varför man inte tog Shopify.
Men, det hade märkats så mycket.
Jag är ganska teknikinisterad.
Vi hade märkats så mycket med Prestakocken om åren och lagt på olika funktioner.
Så det nästan bråk i samman.
Men då hittade vi den setup en centra hade då.
Eller flera kunder som vi såg körde centra.
Då kunde vi få exakt den funktionalitet vi ville.
Hyfsat straight forward.
Sen så rann det iväg både tidsmässigt och prismässigt såklart.
Men det hade man nästan räknat med.
Vill du berätta vad det kostar eller?
Det beror på lite om man lägger upp det.
Men sista kostnaden var nästan internt.
Att vi fick sitta så mycket med alla redirekt.
Så jag tror att vi gjorde en exellent med nästan 2000 redirekt.
Så det tog oändligt mycket tid men väldigt skönt har det gjort.
Jag går igen och kollar på deras hemsida och försöker se om de har lagt upp er här som ett av sina märken som de har.
Men ni har inte hamnat där än.
Vilka läshålls det?
Det är klart att de måste skryta med er.
Måste jag?
Kan du inte säga att de ska putta bort Amin och Stronger och Björn Borg?
Ja, om några år får jag återkomma.
Exakt, exakt.
Vad vill du lägga upp mig?
Kan vi prata lite grann om hur du har utvecklats som människa under den här tiden?
Känner du dig som en riktig företagare nu?
Ja men mycket mer än för två år sedan.
Då var vi tre, tror jag, och en halv kanske.
Nu är vi sju.
Vi pratade lite om det sist, även om ingen här har en enskild roll, de gör 100 procent av tiden.
Så börjar det ju bli mycket mer att folk har roller och ansvarsområden på ett annat sätt.
Så att inte alla springer på samma puckar och så där.
Så nu börjar det ju bli, vi pratade lite om det i förra podden också, nu börjar det kännas snart som ett riktigt företag.
Och det är fortfarande nästan snart som ett riktigt företag?
Ja, exakt.
Nu har ni fått igång butiken, ni har gått in i några länder.
Vad tror du är gränsbrukken?
När känns det som att det här är etablerat?
Jag tror det kommer att bli om tre år kanske, när man omsätter 100 miljoner.
Då kommer man ju ytterligare kunna ha några roller till.
Det är ju fortfarande lite sådär.
Det är ju de första man tänkt ner i logistik och vi har Newcomers Manager nu, vi har Ströstad, Månsvara för hemsidan och allting sådant där.
Det finns ju några sådana specialistroller till som man ser fram emot att få in.
Vad gör du?
Vad är ditt jobb?
Nu har jag ju börjat.
Innan satt jag ju väldigt mycket med allting.
Nu har det varit mycket system, eftersom jag är den som är mest tekniskt intern.
Så det har varit mycket och samtidigt som vi bytte plattform har det varit mycket systemskiften och sådär.
Så mycket har jag fått sitta med det.
Och nu har vi även byggt ett eget inköpssystem.
Eller jag har byggt.
Så nu har det varit mycket att förenkla.
Just det som vi pratade om innan, det här med inköpen och komplexitet kring det ökar.
Just då försöker vi bygga bort det med smidiga system istället.
Men är det det som, för vi hamnar egentligen här för att vi pratar om nästa inköpsdrivare.
Menar du egentligen att dels att ni får liksom bättre konvertering och är det det du menar är liksom den stora inköpsdrivaren?
Eller bättre lagerkontroll för att ni får ett beslut på saker i lager?
Är det bara att affären rullar bättre?
Eller finns det några konkreta nya inkörsportar för människor?
Framförallt så har vi tagit bort allt på hemsidan som bara att det fungerade.
Så det är nog många som bara vände i dörren för att det var slut och inte gick på att handla ordentligt.
Vi stoppade med alla uppdateringar samt på gamla hemsidan när vi bestämde att vi skulle migrera.
Det var lite roligt för även innan satte vi och pillade och justerade hela tiden.
Vi märkte ingen skillnad nästan fast vi slutade röra den.
Så jag tror att jag har överskattat lite hur viktigt det var att hålla på och ändra saker och funktioner på hemsidan hela tiden.
Utan går det riktigt snabbt och allt är enkelt och det är good enough.
Sen får du inte se för tråkigt ut eller sådär men jag tror man nästan har överskattat ibland hur viktigt det är att sitta och pilla på hemsidan och ändra och tona med saker.
Det har varit en grej som har lyft, att allting funkar och det går bra.
Sen så inköp och sånt har varit att vi har haft slut på saker innan och mycket har varit för att vi har missat och att vi inte har haft riktiga systemstöd för det.
De har missat och scenen har slut eller inte haft något riktigt prognosverktyg.
Nu har vi det som gör att så länge man växer och det går fort så kommer det alltid att få slut på vissa grejer.
Det kan vara att fabriken står stilla några månader eller att det är någon båt som fastar i en kanal eller vad som helst.
Jag ska bara säga att jag upplever nästan att det var den riktiga.
För folk kommer tänka sådär, ja men det är väl ingen riktig tillväxtdrivare.
Men det är en jävla tillväxtdrivare för att jag upplever att vi gör extremt lite annorlunda nu mot vad vi gjorde när vi omsatte typ 50.
Alltså det som är bättre nu är att inköpen är bättre.
Det är att allting rullar bättre.
Det finns roller för allting så att allting klickas upp.
Det är bara att man är lite mer på bollen.
Och det gör en jävla skillnad i affären för att är en stor säljare slut i två veckor då tappar man inte bara det säljet utan dessutom blir marknadsföringen helt off och så börjar man sälja någon annan produkt och så blir det fel prognos på den produkten för att man köpte in för många sådana när man egentligen inte kommer att säljas om man har stor säljan i lag.
Det på något sätt spelar på varandra.
Att man får koll på allting är en jävla skillnad i affären.
I går kväll så satte jag att en viss del av sätten väntade på att säljas slut.
Då fick jag lite panik där så de mesta år inköpslån som är ansvarad för inköp och sånt och kollade hur det låg till och då var det en order på väg nästa vecka redan.
Den kollen hade vi inte för två år sen när vi pratade och det hade ju varit några hundratusen eller några miljoner i alla fall, om man inte har rätt skor i maj, det får inte ske om man ska växa vidare.
Jag köper det.
Jag tror att folk underskattar hur man lägger ofta för mycket tid på att tänka, vad ska vi dra in för ny kategori, vilket nytt dokument ska vi göra här, istället bara, fan har du koll på det du gör?
Efter en viss folie, jag fattar i början att man behöver ett visst antal produkter, men sen är det ganska mycket, bara få koll på the basics, så kan man växa ganska mycket på det.
Det är sjukt underskattat.
Sen har vi vissa länder, nu har vi, vi har ju sajten på svenska, norska, danska, tyska, engelska, finska, så där har vi lite fler länder vi hoppas kunna dra igång.
Under året får man se, man vet inte riktigt hur det är, hur svenska och spanska och allt sånt där, hur språknoga de är egentligen där, om det hjälper att lansera lokala språk där, så det är något vi hoppas på också.
De säger väl att de är extremt språknoga, brukar man säga att franskmän inte köper om de inte är på franska.
De är ju sådana tyskar typ.
Ja men exakt, och tyska har vi kört på tyska länge.
Någon väldigt dålig tyska men det funkar ändå.
Ja, en sak som är rätt imponerande, om man går in och kollar på er kurva är att ni växer med lönsamhet hela tiden.
Och har ändå en liten marginal på det.
Vi växer med lönsamhet men det är ju typ hundratusen i resultat.
Ni växer ändå med lönsamhet med några miljoner.
Kan du prata lite om hur man faktiskt lyckas växa med lönsamhet och inte bara växa med förlust helt enkelt.
Vad är ni duktiga på?
Ja, från början egentligen så hade jag alltid 10% på sista raden som ambition att vi skulle ligga där.
Så det var egentligen från början så styrde jag nästan allt emot att vi skulle ha 10% på sista raden.
Sen så nackdelen med det har varit att vi har vuxit lite väl långsamt ibland.
Jag kanske skulle ha anställt ett år tidigare eller ett år tidigare med all anställningar så att vi hade fått ännu snabbare utväxling.
Vi vill ju ett normalt år att ligga på 10% på sista raden och sen kan det bli lite sämre om...
Förra året tog vi väldigt stora investeringar i IT och plattformspyt och sånt där så då tog vi det rakt av.
Det är därför det procentuellt gick ner lite men det kommer ju att gå upp i år.
Allt går som det ska.
Vi har väldigt lite overhead, onödigt...
Jag kan inte komma på några sån här onödiga större kostnadsposter vi har.
Utan det är väldigt svimmrat och många som gör mycket olika saker i ansvarsanålden.
Så snart när vi växer lite till kommer man.
Men att vi har tagit in en logistikansvarig, det är sådana saker och där ser man ju att det kommer att behövas inom ekonomi och sådana delar också inom kort här.
För att få lika bra koll på det som man får på inköp och sådana saker.
Jag vill bara poängtera det du sa.
Du sa att från början har ni räknat med att ha 10 procent.
Jag tror att det är rätt ofta när man startar en e-handel så tänker man att jag ska få igång omsättning och sen tänker man att jag ska lyckas ta ut en lön.
Och då styr man ju på något sätt priserna och affären kring det.
Man styr ju ofta inte sin affär från start att man ska tjäna 10 procent på sista nivån.
Det gjorde i alla fall inte jag.
Men det gör ju att man sätter sin prissättning och sin marknadsföring liksom ut efter det och så får man se om det funkar eller inte.
Nackdelen kanske är att det finns affärer som funkar på 5 procent men inte på 10, men uppenbarligen har det ju funkat i det här fallet.
Så jag tror man ska ta med sig det bara.
Jag tror att det är en sund tanke liksom.
Har du några smarta råd till e-handlare här på slutet?
Kan du säga vad som har gjort att du har lyckats ta dig ifrån när vi säger 10 miljoner till 50?
För det finns väl många som omsätter kanske 10 någonstans.
Vad var det viktigaste på den vägen?
Något som alltid har funkat skulle jag säga.
Sen har det alltid varit puckar när det inte har varit strul och sådär.
Men överlag har ju alltid leveranser och allting som har funkat.
Du har fått den här saker inom utlovad tid.
Sen är det inte alltid, det är ju som till vissa länder, där säger vi ju mycket längre leveranser än det egentligen är.
Och så länge, det är väldigt sällan någon hör av sig och säger att de måste ha något imorgon, någon enstaka satsning ska på brullöppen natt.
Men generellt sett så räcker det att hålla dem tidigare lova.
I början hade man ju panikat att de var tvungna att få det dagen efter varje gång.
Nu levererar vi allt i dagen efter ändå men inte till alla länder och det behövs inte heller utan det räcker att hålla sejl i tio dagar, nu är det att vi är dem.
Vi har aldrig varit med om att en leverans är att de inte har handlat för att det är för långt utlovad leverans till så länge vi håller det.
Logistiken har alltid funkat.
Nu har vi bytt ett väldigt bra lag här men innan så kunde det lagga lite på hjul och så där.
Men det har ju alltid hållit marknadsföringen också, man har aldrig vannat tak på marknadsföringen utan så länge du kan kolla att den är lönsäm så ska du vara frit blåst där att du kan annonsera hur mycket som helst.
Där ska du aldrig sätta någon budget för att du inte ska annonsera mer än x kronor.
Så länge du vet att den är lönsäm så ska du vara rädd att läsa på.
Ja det gillar jag också faktiskt.
Den kan jag signa under på ganska hårt.
Vi kan liksom slå en halv miljon mellan månader i marknadsföring.
Skulle vi ha satt en budget så hade det varit helt flippigt.
Men det hade inte funkat.
För ibland tar det fart och jag tänker att ni är ännu värre för ni är kanske lite...
Är det schysst väder nu i maj då vill folk ut liksom.
Det som egentligen är svårast är väl att ha en riktigt bra produkt, till ett riktigt bra pris.
Och det vet ju, vi har ju, eller jag vet ju det, sen har jag väl partisk, men vi har ju de bästa skolorna till det bästa priset.
Sen finns det ju andra som är bättre på att se häftigare ut och se coolare ut och som äser ut.
Säger man häftig och cool nu?
Ja men jag undrar.
Fan vad häftig den ser ut.
Nej men det finns ju, som har mycket dyrare influencers, som betalar rejält för dyra influencers och som skriver mycket av skolorna, kanske gör en annonsering och sånt som inte stämmer riktigt.
Men vi vet ju att vi har ju bäst produkt till bäst pris, så det vi behöver bli bättre på är ju att nå ut med det också och förmedla det.
Men så länge du har bästa produkten och har ett bra pris på den, då har du liksom en edge mot alla andra.
Nu, det här har jag inte med de här grejerna, det bara dyker upp där.
Ni har bytt logistik, sa du, och ni kör väl tredjepartsslager.
Ja.
Och jag har investerat i ett bolag som också har tredjepartslogistik och jag blir ju helt dum i huvudet av det.
Det är en jävla massa bök liksom.
Och jag fattar den inte, för vi har ju eget lag och jag tycker att det är så logiskt.
Men fan vad krångligt det är med tredjepartslogistik och hitta folk som är duktiga och vad man ska kolla efter.
Så kommer det massa konstiga kostnader och det där sker.
Har du något tips kring att liksom, vad fan ska man, vad blåser tredjepartslogistikarna än på?
Vad är det man ska kolla efter?
Vad är det man ska fråga?
Kan du bara ge någon sorts tips?
För fan jag fattar ingenting, helvete vad krångligt det är.
Jag kan tänka mig också att det är väldigt olika på vad du säljer för grejer.
Hade du haft tredjepartslogistik som skickade dina dikter?
Detta är smågrejer, så ni ligger i samma genrer.
Vi har haft två olika trepjällare, det har varit väldigt stor skillnad.
Man har framförallt hittat en prismodell som funkar för ens produkter och för det flödet man har.
Vi har haft lite olika varianter där vi har betalt per paket och per timme.
Det gäller att hitta en prismodell där de debiterar dig på ett upplägg som passar dig bra.
Det kommer massor av extra timmar för extra jobb som att du inte vet vad det är.
Där man får be er vara noga och vara på.
Sen är jag jävligt snål så jag har ju på dem att fråga om spekulation på alla timmar.
Att försöka bygga bort de timmarna så är det mycket möjligt så man vill ju egentligen inte ha mer än fallplatser och så vill du ha kostnader för att skicka ett paket i typ det du vill ha.
Du vill inte ha massa administration och tilläggstimmar.
Är du inte rädd för att de ska hata dig?
Jo, det är ständig räddsel.
Jag tycker att vi har rätt bra dialog med OTPL och så länge det funkar från dem så funkar det bra för oss.
Sen så gör vi grejer som de tycker är jobbiga också.
Jag fick någon bild på någon container som lagret hade skickat där allt var staplat.
Det skulder dem buller.
Vi har i alla fall med vår partner en bra balans i det där.
Jag tror vi hjälps åt så det funkar väldigt bra.
Det är väldigt lite kontakt vi behöver ha kring det.
Har man jobbat med det i tio år så lär man sig redan innan man börjar jobba med en ny, det är det man måste ha koll på.
Men den stora grejen egentligen är att gå in i dialogen med tredjepartslogistiken och liksom, jag skulle vilja bli faktererad enligt den här prismodellen, kan man göra på det sättet?
Ja, jag vet inte alls hur de jobbar.
Men vi har ju en modell över betalaren per paket egentligen.
Eller du säger att det är så krångligt så jag vet inte riktigt vad det är som är så krångligt.
För det är ju att betala för att de skickar paket upp.
Ja men, och så är det den här kostnaden per rad och så är det här för en retur och så är det här för en hylla.
Och sen när man kollar hyllorna, då har de lagt sakerna på tre olika hyllor som har betalat tre olika hyllor för en hylla som kunde vart en hylla och tog emot...
Vårt gamla lager kunde säkert vara så.
För då har du ju betalat för hyllmeter och både det som kan stå på hyllor och sen har du pallplatser och sånt där där det säkert kan optimeras.
Det kan ju finnas 3PL som kanske låter det stå en halvton pall på två platser så får den ju hundra spänn mer i månaden.
Men jag är väldigt nädd med vår 3PL idag så att vi har något riktigt av utmaningen nu men klart är man inte nöjd och måste flytta sådär då är det klart att det är en utmaning med logistiken.
Även om man lejer ut den så är det ju alltid en massa jobb med logistiken då.
Även om att det packar och plockar själv.
Jag tror att det är kanske den stora grejen att folk tänker ibland att man lägger ut det på 3PL och då är det inget problem.
Det är fortfarande en stor punkt av din tid som kommer att gå till att snacka logistik.
Sen måste du ha en helt annan systematik med det här med streckkoder och ordning och reda på allting.
Har du eget lag kan du bara ha någon som kan allt som hittar det ändå.
Men det är rätt bra också att bli tvingad till den här systematiken också så att man får lite extra i baken på styrup så att det är riktig ordning och reda på allt.
Det låter sunt.
Emil, stort tack för att du var med.
Jag hoppas vi hörs igen om två och ett halvt år.
Jag sätter timelineen där så krossar ni nästa siffer kombination då.
Ja, det ska vi göra.
Ja, tack för att du var med.
Tack själv.
Ha en underår vecka.
Ja, ha det samma.
Ha det gott.
Nu senast skrev jag i kontorschatten här, hej vad heter sådana här snören som drar åt sig själva på skorna?
Jag ska försöka hitta de skorna jag köpte för två år sen när jag ville ha samma skor.